[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chanteurs de Saint-Eustache ont
beaucoup faits pour le renom de cette
église parisienne connue dans le monde
entier et c'est de loin qu'on est venu
entendre le concert qu'il vienne de
consacrer à l'œuvre de Haendel sous la
direction du père Martin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces chanteurs sont les continuateurs
d'une grande tradition car si
Saint-Eustache est considéré comme l'une
des plus belles églises de Paris elle
est également chère aux amateurs de
musique Lully simaria on y célébra les
obsèques de Rameau et de la mère de
Mozart Berlioz révéla son TDM liste y
joua sa messe de grand
[Musique]
à son arrivée à New York les
photographes n'ont plus admirer qu'une
de ces reproductions la Joconde ne
devint pas quitter comme on sait sa
caisse d'aluminium jamais passagère venu
du Vieux Continent n'aura été entouré
d'autant d'attention jalouse que Mona
Lisa on avait prévu un camion blindé et
climatisé escorté par 50 policiers
le printemps il est vrai que la toile de
Léonard de Vinci vaut plus que le
paquebot France qu'il a transporté ce
qui force le respect
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise qu'a vécu le Sénégal n'a duré
que 48 heures la tentative du président
du Conseil Mamadou Dia d'imposait sa
volonté à l'Assemblée régulièrement élue
à échouer quelques heures après son
investissement l'Assemblée nationale
était dégagée par les troupes fidèles au
président singes
d'autre part les installations de la
radio avaient vu les adversaires tour à
tour maître du micro mais malgré les
interventions de différentes troupes
personne ne parvenait à achever son
appel au peuple
le lendemain matin monsieur dia
regagnait sa villa il avait beau à
ranguer quelques partisans les jeux
étaient faits car le peuple sénégalais
était resté fidèle au président de la
République Léopold Sédar Senghor
les représentants de la nation ont été
expulsés de leur lieu de réunion et
plusieurs ont été arrêtés déclaré le
président singor j'ai réquisitionné les
forces militaires car le dernier mot
doit rester à la loi
les Sénégalais avaient pris conscience
des dangers provoqués par l'entreprise
de subversion en envahissant l'Assemblée
nationale ils entendaient protéger leur
députés et en inclamant mettre la midget
président de l'Assemblée il confirmait
leur attachement au président singor en
48 heures le Sénégal achevé sa
révolution tentative de coup d'état
épuration et réforme tendantes au régime
présidentiel
et pourtant pendant ces événements à
l'ombre des clochers des églises ultra
modernes de la capitale du Sénégal les
préparatifs de Noël ont suivi leurs
cours tranquilles et les vous toutes
blanches ont retentit des champs
traditionnels curieusement rythmées par
les voisins infantiles
[Musique]
lancer au mois d'août mariner II a donc
accompli la mission fixée par les
techniciens américains il a transmis
toute une série d'observations faites à
30000 km de Vénus
[Musique]
renseignement précieux puisque l'homme
n'est pas presse en doute d'y aller voir
lui-même par contre le voyage pour la
lune semble imminent sera pour 1963
[Musique]
ce n'est pas anticipé beaucoup en tout
cas que de vous convier dès aujourd'hui
au voyage sur notre satellite confort
d'abord vous aurez pris la précaution de
retenir une fusée couchette
et par une belle nuit terrestre vous
aurez commencé de la façon la plus
classique qui soit cette petite
excursion de
384000 km imagée d'après les dernières
observations astronomiques
au petit déjeuner vous découvrirez par
le hublot des cratères désolé
[Musique]
l'apparition des grands cirques lunaires
vous apprendra que le terme du voyage
est proche
avant d'aller notre pilote s'installera
sur orbite tourisme pour vous permettre
de voir se dérouler sous vos yeux cette
mer des pluies dont la particularité est
d'être d'une aridité totale
[Musique]
devant vous ce dressera la grande chaîne
des à peines lunaires haute montagne
dont certains sommets culmine à plus de
8000 mètres
tout à coup vous serez en face du mur
droit sorte de Falaise robe de 800
mètres qui s'étend sur des centaines de
kilomètres
enfin sur les plaines poussiéreuses vous
verrez briller le fameux clair de terre
[Musique]
Paris compte 61 clubs différents du club
des choses au club des fumeuses de pipes
ou au club des timides le club des
solitaires lui à cette particularité
concis écrase un sage n'a-t-il pas dit
c'est au milieu de la foule qu'on se
sent seul quoi qu'il en soit si
solitaires triés sur le volet rêver du
titre envier semble-t-il de Miss
solitude pourquoi elles l'ont dit
nettement
pas cette élection de trouver peut-être
une jeune homme qui ferait mon bonheur
et l'heureux élu qu'en pense-t-elle
pourquoi étiez vos candidates au titre
de Miss solitude pourquoi être Miss
solitude et bien pour faciliter les
relations et connaître des gens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en très bonne voie même qui donc a dit
l'homme n'est pas fait pour vivre seul
les solitaires non plus
[Musique]
il faut dire que les nuits de Paris ne
manquent pas de pôle d'attraction en
cette fin d'année pour fasciner ceux qui
sont à jouer les noctambules le Lido
pour sa part a offert à Monsieur Roger
frère Michel Morgan à Jean-Claude Brialy
la nouvelle revue de Pierre-Louis Guérin
une personnalité au mètre carré grant
aimait le ferrer en vedette américaine
et un brillant spectacle sur la scène
[Musique]